when is chris going to be on our flag
means death and what character should he
play
uh
blonde beard long beard uh yeah um
when he's receiving that offer
that offer it's been check your inbox
yeah spam mail obviously all these are
really cool things taika is doing on the
side and i'm like oh that's weird i
didn't get a
single text a phone call about it yeah
same with you um you tell george miller
we're waiting for mine
but
i am actually like if he were to text
you and say with our flag means death
would you like to do it is it one of
these things where you would actually do
it i'd do whatever he asked me to do and
i would do whatever he asked me i'd i'd
be
you know i'm i'm we're two for you so
any chance to come and play together and
do things it's like i was watching those
uh thor and daryl short films you know
those things that we did
and that was really just like to test
out this new version of thor we were
just before we did these tiny little
like thor flatting in australia uh with
the still character daryl and
and this is a great man
i don't think if we hadn't done that i
don't know that the film would have had
the same same tone yeah
we just kind of went for it and it
became wacky and mockumentary style and
and uh and then on we went so i've heard
the movie has a lot of deleted scenes as
you know first of all yeah i've heard
this um you guys are two for two i
i love the way you guys work together
like i'm speaking for all fans when i
say that the movie's about two hours i
would have taken a four hour movie so
what how how long was your first cut
like are there a lot of deleted scenes
about four hours it was about four hours
and a lot of time on set we were talking
about this before like when
in the moment you're like this is the
greatest thing with that anyone's ever
filmed in the history of filming things
and you get into the edit you're like
it's still kind of like it and then
after about six months of it being in
the movie you realize
it's like it was fun on the day
it doesn't have any business being in
the movie batshit crazy wild
four hour cut i've ever seen yeah oh you
wait wait you actually saw him yeah
there are so many things in there i mean
one day it will it should be you we need
a director to cut like or the
whatever you want to call it it's like
the anyone's cut the anyone's car yeah
the assembly of the film the
everything's bagel it was about four
hours
it was like a monty python sketch yeah i
see when people say the four hour cut
i'm like oh that's the assembly people
are never going to see it but it was an
actual so it's a four hour actual movie
pretty much i wouldn't call it him i
feel like it's more of an assembly i
think you're right it's more of an
assembly an assembling of like
madness like a lot it really like about
five times it just gives up on the story
and just like just
10 15. the story was sacrificed
and then yeah so let me ask you this if
you were to actually release like an
extended cut of this movie that was
longer than two hours like how long do
you think it would be
that actually it seems you were really
happy with it would you do that would
you ever go i don't know
i don't want to see the end of the
footage ever again in my life yeah
it's so tiring and like
last thing i want to go i was like i
guess let's try that scene again
the film has got a strong structure now
yeah anything else we put in like a big
long scene like zigzag you know
you know like a bunch of soldiers going
to have dinner with some french people
on a river you know like you know if we
put a big long scene like that and i
feel like
something sorry
i think i have to rap already i'm just
gonna which sucks i'm just gonna say
listen you guys are two for two i really
hope you're making another film together
very soon thanks right
we should let's say yes
you